j'aimerais jouer à l'avant ce pour quoi
vous vous paraissez vendre bien pourquoi
ils me regardent en face il me dit je me
réjouis à l'avancé les mois fait son
souffre douleur c'est bien ça non et
vous savez pourquoi parce qu'on a le
même âge et que j'ai l'air tellement
plusieurs
citations
pour avoir l'air si jeune et si mal pays
acp
oui très bon public 1 c'est génial très
bonne ambiance taillon ce qui serait
bien c'est si vous pouvez lancer des
trucs par exemple des vêtements ou du
pognon ça serait vraiment ça mettrait
l'ambiance
d
celle du moment où tu fais la ferme ta
100 mille euros qui vont rentrer un
salaire brut on doit dire presque cent
mille euros en brut toi c'est quoi mais
c'était il ya longtemps mérité au
bout de piste au total cent mille euros
le vrai suppression de la chaire et
jusqu'à la fin j'ai fait la finale
j'arrivais à paris sur le plateau mais
sortira donc cent mille euros c'est de
la semaine en avez un salaire qui serait
ce truc devant clément où tu touches à
et puis après il faut vivre avec pendant
un an ou deux ouais puis comme avant tv
un peu déconné mais les impôts ils sont
bien servir et magie ça va très vite on
a parlé de mba paix pendant un an savoir
si l oral de madrid au paris saint
germain mais le transfert de l'année
c'est qu'un michel drucker sur france 3
sas applaudissaient
c'est la dernière
vous avez pris 100 millions aussi ou pas
c'est l'ancien franco est il intervenu
en france non mais si c'est le sérieux
c'est le nadal de france télé avec plus
de cheveux et - piqué mais c'est lui à
je me présente je m'appelle soit de mu
j'ai trente trois ans or
je m'accuse way marche parisienne notre
machine banlieusards merci papa dans le
costume spam alcool rangez vos frères
ange et opèrent en ue marie d'ikos sont
pas de mu et l'archivé beau
endemol france télévisons use ghana mais
je vous propose
25% à l'épicerie de la blache
25% mais tu sais quoi non non on arrête
de dire que chez nous tous les jours je
sais quand même c'est quoi dans une
ville du nord-ouest de l'espagne la
municipalité a publié un nouveau
règlement toute personne surprise en
train de dîner sur le sable ou dans
l'océan recevra une amende très salée
nathalie de
750 euros bien d'autres jeux de mots et
la mairie n'a pas indiqué comment il
comptait s'y prendre pour identifier les
contrevenants n'ont même pas dire tu es
une fille sans secret ah oui sert à la
salle du jour s'associent le vainqueur
du tour m'est arrivé quelque chose à
hobart il manquait non moi j'aime bien
comme ça j'ai parlé de mes galères et
j'entends beaucoup mieux que certaines
pêches et d'ailleurs on a beaucoup qui
sont venus me soutenir aujourd'hui dans
le public est ce que vous êtes venus me
soutenir parce que vous voulez mon cul
oui voilà donc à la casse avait la
question enfin bref c'est ce à quoi on a
toutes les filières sont vraiment avoir
une mentalité de chârost j'aime bien
qu'on voit mais tt et mes fesses c'est
mes atouts principaux
tt tt quoi c'est quoi mais à tous oui
mais tu t'es arabe
alors léon né voilà là
en fait ces choses pour tes les
vêtements que les gens anormaux hills au
spa quoi ah ouais non non on confirme
diam's n'est plus parce que voilà moi je
suis que mélanie mais pour moi diam's a
vraiment été un une étape dans ma vie
c'est quelque chose qui est là qui a
existé en plus aux yeux de millions de
personnes pour moi en fait je suis pas
devenu mélanie je suis
redevenu peut-être mais c'est quand même
une différence entre s'habiller sexy et
s'habiller serré oui enfin après moi
j'ai pris un peu de poids mais encore il
ne sait pas mais on fait du s est
enfui jesse donc voilà je force
laurent et nous envoient des espèces de
bonjour plastique là je suis au bout de
ma vie je pensais qu'ils allaient
nouvelles de trois jours à l'hôtel le
temps que le cyclone y passe mais
clairement pas du tout on reste dans
notre galère quand genou van rossom tous
à des préservatifs humeur on ressemble à
rien des sacs poubelles il se passe
quelque chose de fou et en fait on
ressemble tout ça que d'aller en plus en
a que dalle à se mettre sous la dent
combien d'années de carrière - il y
soixante ans yato vous continuez vous
avez tous vos points retraite arouna
koné et pisa gtug et traîné et c'est
pour ça que macro il nous saoulent avec
sa réforme il vous vois bosser dit vas-y
les vieux on les tire sco bouard